My comedian peers they told me
"Hey, man, professionals,
they don't sing,
they tell the jokes."
And I was just going onstage
just singing Montell Jordan.
That was my thing.
That was my comedy.
And they were like,
"Hey, as, you know,
professional comedians,
that's not how we do it."
So I was like, cool, all right.
I'll focus
on the written material,
the spoken joke, whatever.
But I felt like I was,
you know,
putting my superpower away.
That's like telling Tyler Perry,
"No more dresses, dog."
But then comes the "Comedy Jam."
An opportunity for me,
James Davis,
to go back to his roots.
[cheers and applause]
So, tonight,
ladies and gentlemen,
if you guys are ready,
I'm ready.
[band plays
"This Is How We Do It"]
♪ This is how we do it ♪
♪ ♪
♪ Sha la-la-la-la
la-la-la la-la ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ This is how we do it ♪
♪ It's Friday night,
and I feel all right ♪
♪ The party's here
on the west side ♪
♪ So I reach for my 40
and I turn it up ♪
♪ Designated driver
take the keys to the truck ♪
♪ Hit the shore
'cause I'm faded ♪
♪ Honeys in the street say,
"Monty, yo, we made it!" ♪
♪ It feels so good
in my hood tonight ♪
♪ The summertime skirts
and the guys in Kani ♪
♪ All the gang bangers
forgot about the drive-by ♪
Time-out, time-out,
time-out, time-out.
[song stops]
You know how lit it's gotta be
for you to forget about
a drive-by?
Don't we have a murder planned?
[song resumes]
♪ You gotta get your groove on ♪
♪ Before you go get paid ♪
♪ So tip up your cup
and throw your hands up ♪
♪ And let me hear
the party say ♪
♪ I'm kinda buzzed
and it's all because ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ South Central does it
like nobody does ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ To all my neighbors
you got much flavor ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ Let's flip the track,
bring the old school back ♪
Montell Jordan!
- ♪ This is how we do it ♪
♪ All hands are in the air ♪
♪ And wave 'em from here
to there ♪
♪ If you're an O.G. mack
or a wannabe player ♪
♪ You see the hood's
been good to me ♪
both: ♪ Ever since
I was a lowercase G ♪
♪ But now I'm a big G ♪
♪ The girls see
we got the money ♪
- ♪ Dollar-dollar bills y'all ♪
- ♪ If you were from ♪
both: ♪ Where I'm from ♪
♪ Then you would know ♪
- ♪ That I gotta get mine
in a big black truck ♪
both: ♪ You can get yours
in a '64 ♪
♪ Whatever it is,
the party's under way ♪
- ♪ So tip up your cup
and throw your hands up ♪
both: ♪ And let me hear
the party say ♪
- ♪ I'm kinda buzzed
and it's all because ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ Ooh, South Central does it
like nobody does ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ To all my neighbors
you got much flavor ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ Let's flip the track,
bring the old school back ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- We got it!
♪ Once upon a time in '94 ♪
- Uh-huh.
- ♪ Montell made some money ♪
♪ And life sure was slow ♪
- Uh-huh.
- ♪ All they said was
6'8" he stood ♪
- Uh-huh.
- ♪ People thought the music ♪
♪ That you made was good ♪
- Okay.
- ♪ There lived a DJ
and Paul was his name ♪
- Uh-huh.
- ♪ He came up to you ♪
♪ And this is what he said ♪
- What'd he say?
- ♪ You and O.G.
are gonna make some cash ♪
♪ Sell a million records
and we'll make in a dash ♪
both: ♪ Said I'm kinda buzzed
and it's all because ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
both: ♪ South Central does it
like nobody does ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ Nobody ♪
- ♪ To all my neighbors ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- ♪ Nobody ♪
both: ♪ Nobody ♪
♪ Nobody ♪
chorus: ♪ This is how we do it ♪
- Sing it!
- ♪ Nobody ♪
[cheers and applause]
♪ Nobody ♪